[Music]
okay so I had stopped doing episode by
episode reviews of Legion season 2
because after doing only two of them I
realized that I was basically sitting
down in front of the camera every
episode and going I'm not entirely sure
what I just watched but I think I liked
it and just repeating that each time I
was like this makes for boring reviews
and I don't know what to say about this
I'm gonna wait till the end and I have
now gotten through the whole thing and
oh boy how do I spoil er I guess insofar
as something that I'm not entirely sure
I understood in its entirety
can be spoiled but yeah this is the see
overall season review so keep that in
mind I liked season 1 of Legion a lot
and I really appreciated the sort of
depths that we learned about the
characters involved in sort of the way
that that settings that we're kind of
building on trying to understand the
either mental conditions or powers of
the characters really lent itself to
that initially starting out with the
mental hospital and then the facility
where the mutants were so that all
seemed to fit what they were doing
really well so knowing that that coming
into this one it was gonna be more of a
chase possibly even a road kind of movie
as as they tried to hunt down Farouk the
shadow king I was kind of like is it
gonna become too straightforward
is it gonna become too normal and then
you know first episode had the had the
mental dance-off battle the hey yeah I
was like no no danger this becoming to
normal like I
I would be really interested if anybody
could work out what percentage of what
of the one time of this second season
actually takes place in what is
presented to be reality as opposed to
sealed off mental places or future
projections or mind scapes or you know
alter realities are all these other
things because I I'm pretty dead
certains it's definitely less than 15% I
betcha it hovers more around like 25 so
that that should tell you a lot about
what you're getting from this this is a
show that like I can say this about a
number of things about a number of shows
about a number of movies that this is
something you have to pay attention to
this isn't something to like you know
check your text messages while watching
and still get something out of it you do
need to pay attention but the thing I
have to add an extra caveat with this
one just because you pay full attention
it does not mean you'll fully understand
what's going on and that can be really
tricky to do well for me the way this
does it works very well because it never
feels like it's withholding information
I never feels like it's confusing or I'm
going wait huh because they missed a
detail or they failed to show me
something I feel that way because
they're showing me all the stuff I need
but all the stuff I need is hard to wrap
my head around like as concepts and
that's the kind of confusing I enjoy
because it challenges me without
frustrating me at least into my tastes
so I really did enjoy this season I I
don't know if I liked it more than the
than the first season it's it's a tough
one I don't I don't think it has the
same narrative build to it there was
something about the the unraveling of
David specifically in the first seasons
especially as we learned things about
the shadow king about Farouk and about
Lenny and things like that and the pace
at which over the
and all that started to come apart that
I don't think the second season quite
measures up to that said the second
season goes further with it's bonkers
miss but again keeps it just tepid
enough to what passes for the reality of
this show that it works for me if I were
to nitpick there was one thing that was
starting to get to me as the season went
on but then basically the last episode
pulled it out of the fire and that is
that David as a character was not
entirely there for me now that he was a
bad character but that I didn't really
have a sense of him as a personality in
terms of a power set and like a couple
of key relationships okay but if I if
asked to describe David as a person I
would have been kind of hard-pressed to
do so he was kind of hard to read he was
arguably even generic at times and that
was that was something that I was
starting to realize it and he might have
been this way in the first season too
but because we were learning about him I
was more okay with that at this point I
felt like I should be getting a better
sense of his personality I'm not
and what I say kind of pulled it that
out of the fire at the last episode I
mean that they go with he's not the hero
he's the problem and it's not it's not
quite the same thing but it reminded me
rather a lot of the turn of the
character of Ward and agents of shield
the first season of Ages of shields Ward
was generic as hell and then towards the
end of the first season revealed to be a
sleeper agent for Hydra the nvme thing
that they were fighting against the
entire time and suddenly his being
generic and bland made sense he was
trying to blend in so here it's not
quite the same thing because it's not
like David was deliberately trying to
trick everybody he was tricking himself
into thinking he was the good guy but
that's sort of the thing
was sort of internally shaving off his
edges making himself as as smooth and
presentable as possible not even without
even completely realizing it so as to
present as what the closest thing he
could be to a hero and it does paper
over that a bit I'm not sure entirely
does I think he still possibly came
across as a little bit too bland in
certain chunks of the second season but
that move at the very end does make up
for a lot of that so I don't I honestly
don't really have an overall like
glaring issue I like if there was
another nitpick like with Lenny with
that character I enjoyed Lenny most
being threatening and malevolent in the
first season but that was very much
Lenny as possessed by Farooq so and we
got Lenny on her own this season she was
back to sort of the scatterbrained
frantic druggie which isn't bad it's
just you kind of you took it away from
from what I really liked about Aubrey
Plaza's performance in the first season
but again at work because it's not like
we lost Farouk and this was this is a
tricky thing to do because in the first
season she for me became the face of the
shadow king in the face of Farouk much
more so than that yelloweye devil thing
so this season to move that to an actor
who we hadn't seen before and still have
that translate and not have it feel like
swapping out Colin Farrell Johnny Depp
at the end of fantastic beasts and be
like it's the same bill I'm like it
really doesn't feel like it and it
doesn't feel like that because that he
this guy was able to embody all those
elements of that character that ivory
Plaza brought to it when she played it
so that did actually work and I was
surprised I wasn't expecting it to
there's a lot of questioning of
loyalties in this one there's a lot of
who's on whose side and it's interesting
because because of the mind-bending
nature of the narrative it's not quite
as exhausting as constant back stabs and
flip flops can be in something more
straightforward like say espionage spy
story the the
unique presentation and angle of the
mental end of this whole story honestly
does a lot to make things that I know
wouldn't work for me in a more
straightforward story at the very least
not bother me if not actually work for
me
so I mentioned David being a little weak
there are some very good performers I
actually really took to carry and carry
in this one I liked them last season but
I felt like I really really got into
them this season I feel like I
understood Sid a bit better by the end
of this season
you know what episode really got to me
and what whole sort of sequence I was
like oh my god was the realization of
where Lenny got her body from and what
happened to David's sister and watching
that play out and having it sink in what
it was that actually happened that that
actually hit an emotional note that I
wasn't sure the show could do because
when something is this sort of on on an
intellectual mental trying to figure it
out level it can be hard to engage
emotionally because you have to
understand what's going on well enough
to be emotionally engaged and and that
that's a tricky thing to balance but
here they really did pull that off quite
well with that moment I think that
episode I think was my favorite episode
that said my favorite section moment of
the whole thing the opening of the last
episode with David singing behind blue
eyes and him Farooq with this animated
mental battle it was like watching the
two of them fight it was like it was
like a cut scene out of the animated
sections of Pink Floyd's the wall it was
awesome and amazing and I loved it and
there's so many great surreal images
like the bath plug the open bath plug in
the middle of the desert and I and I
actually really liked the the sort of
isolated divergences where like this
omniscient narrator talks about you know
these different forms of delusions these
different sort of mental exercises or
thought experiments and
that was really interesting and and
again that was sort of thing that on
paper should take me out of there but it
doesn't it all it all just combines and
feeds into it and it's it's astounding
that this thing works so I'm trying to
think if there was anything else I want
I mean there's there's plenty of stuff
I've just kind of glossed over I've
talked broad strokes but yeah this whole
thing yeah I suppose there were a couple
of things that felt surreal just for the
sake of being surreal like Fukuyama as a
character i find him interesting and his
whole thing was kind of fascinating to
watch but I'm not sure he had a point or
you know I'm not sure there was a reason
for him to be like that other than
here's something really weird and
surreal and by-and-bye season two I was
hoping for more things to feed directly
into the narrative but I'm not sure how
much he did but it was still a very cool
look but yeah this whole this show is
nuts this season was nuts I'll be happy
one more comeback but don't expect me to
ever do episode by episode reviews it's
got to be it's got to be season
overviews if I keep talking about the
show cuz anything else you just can't I
can't digest this one thing at a time
I've got to take in the scope of it and
the scope of it is nuts have you seen
the second season of Legion whatever you
thought drop something down to comments
let's talk about it there's stuff to do
you know all the stuff support me on
patreon like some subscribe and Twitter
and blah blah blah blah blah links for
all that stuff's down in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]